the FBI says it has foiled a plot to
terrorize a popular shopping district in
San Francisco on Christmas Day Everett
Jamison was charged Friday with
attempting to provide material support
to Isis the 26 year old was allegedly
plotting a suicide attack on pier 39 a
destination on San Francisco's
waterfront known for hosting large
crowds of tourists CBS News justice
reporter Paula Reed is in our Washington
bureau Paula what more do we know about
the suspect well Anthony this arrest
comes after an undercover sting
operation that unfolded after the past
several weeks with the FBI uncovered
that Jameson was inspired by Isis and
the recent Halloween truck attack in New
York according to newly unsealed court
documents he told an undercover FBI
source that he wanted to inflict
casualties through the use of vehicle
and Firearms and that he believed that
pier 39 in San Francisco would be an
ideal target Jameson is a 26 year old
tow truck truck driver born in Modesto
California he's also a former Marine but
he was discharged for failing to
disclose a history of asthma Jameson
allegedly offered to use his military
training in combat and Firearms to
support the cause of Isis he was
arrested after the FBI executed a search
warrant on his home then covered
firearms explosive materials and a note
taking credit for the planned attack
Paula you've learned that Jameson was
possibly tipped off about the federal
investigation that's right
according to court documents on December
18th an FBI employee here in Washington
DC with an identifiable phone number
mistakenly called Jameson's cell phone
and then hung up Jamison called the
employee back and it went to voicemail
that identified the employee by name but
it didn't specify that he was calling an
FBI employee now later that day the
undercover FBI agent contacted Jamison
to set up a meeting but he was rebuffed
he was later told by Jameson that he
Jameson thought he couldn't do this and
that he had reconsidered so it appears
that he may have been aware that he
might be under surveillance and no
longer wanted to talk to these sources
all right Paula Reid in Washington Paula
thank you